It is a big day today or yesterday was a big
day, Donald Trump conceded the election to
Joe Biden.
Now, I'm not going to click bait you guys.
Donald Trump did not say I concede to Joe
Biden.
That is not something Donald Trump is likely
to ever say.
But what Donald Trump did say yesterday is,
listen, I'm still suing people, but my administration
is going to move forward and allow the formal
transition to take place for now.
This is Donald Trump and this is the closest
we may ever get to a concession from him.
He's not saying he lost.
He's not saying Biden won.
He's still going to file lawsuits, but he
is allowing the transition to start, which
frees up money for Joe Biden to start the
transition.
And he reportedly did this after being told
by close confidants, including his chief of
staff, Mark Meadows, it's time to start moving
on.
There is no path.
There's really nothing else.
It is time to start moving on.
Now, recall that Donald Trump was holding
up the transition.
That was Emily Murphy from the JESSA'S to
sort of formally put in place.
This is the General Services Administration.
They didn't start the process.
Emily Murphy is a Trump administration official.
Trump had not directed her to start this process
because Donald Trump hadn't conceded and the
pressure continued building.
And finally, after weeks yesterday, Donald
Trump tweeted, I want to thank Emily Murphy
at GSA for her steadfast dedication and loyalty
to our country.
She has been harassed, threatened and abused.
And I do not want to see this happen to her
or her family or employees of GSA.
Our case strongly continues.
We will keep up the good fight and I believe
we will prevail.
No, you won't.
Nevertheless, in the best interest of our
country, I am recommending that Emily and
her team do what needs to be done with regard
to initial protocols.
And I have done I have told my team to do
the same.
So for Donald Trump, this is admitting defeat.
This is the concession.
Nothing else now needs to happen.
Nothing else needed to happen.
Even without this, even without the formal
transition, Joe Biden would become president
on January 20th.
But now there is simply nothing else.
And Donald Trump says he will keep fighting.
He says he still thinks he won.
He's even saying he thinks he will prevail,
but he is allowing the process to start.
Now, on the other end of this, Emily Murphy
wrote a letter to the Biden campaign.
And it is just comically unprofessional and
self-serving.
It is all about her, which I guess runs in
the Trump administration.
Emily Murphy wrote that all the media reports
about her are wrong.
She was not acting politically.
She did nothing incorrect.
She has to ascertain the apparent results
of the presidential election, not impose the
president elect on the country.
She points out she doesn't certify the winner.
She doesn't pick the winner.
There were legal challenges.
And I have to tell you guys, this is all complete
and utter nonsense.
She claims she can't do anything until results
are certified.
That's not true in every election.
The results are not really truly fully certified
until the electors vote in December.
And yet somehow in 2016, GSA started the transition
in November.
In 2012, there was no transition.
But the results were were were as far as the
GSA was concerned, clear within days of the
election.
Same thing in 2008, same thing in the year
2000.
This is absolute and total nonsense.
The whole letter that she wrote is a self
aggrandizing mess, which you can read in full
if you're so inclined.
I don't find it necessary to give you the
full contents of the letter today.
Bottom line is this.
Donald Trump had close aides go to him and
say it's time we have to move on this.
There's really nothing else that we can do.
Donald Trump, without saying I lost fair and
square, without saying Joe Biden will be president,
he said go ahead.
And now she says, Emily Murphy, go ahead.
And this is this is it.
This entire interim period will be an asterisk
in the history books of one of the most dystopian
authoritarian attempts to steal the election.
It will obviously be unsuccessful.
We knew weeks ago that it would be unsuccessful.
And now with the start of the formal transition,
six point three million dollars, it's freed
up for Joe Biden's transition.
Another million is freed up for what's called
appointee orientation being.
Bang, boom.
Things are moving ahead fully and completely
at this point in time.
This is the closest thing we are ever going
to see to a concession from Donald Trump.
Trump has been urged even by many Republicans,
to start this transition more formally.
It's not clear Donald Trump is really listening
to those people.
It seems some of his closest aides came to
him and said, you've got to do it.
You really should do it.
And it is happening.
And we are one step closer to moving on from
this national nightmare of a complete and
total fiasco.
And the questions that remain are really sort
of academic questions, right?
What will Donald Trump do between now and
January 20th?
Will we see him return to the public eye in
any capacity today?
He'll be doing some kind of Thanksgiving turkey
ceremony or something like that with Melania.
Will he ever take questions again?
Will he attend the inauguration?
Will he ever invite Joe Biden to the White
House?
We don't have the answers to these questions.
The the answers are largely irrelevant to
the broader priorities of the country at this
time.
Joe Biden is moving forward.
He continues to make cabinet selections.
And that's what I want to talk about next,
because this
is
really important.